okay hello everybody we are in beautiful
Rome
I am looking up Adela and she is my
choppa lang so what we're gonna do is
something extremely simple we're sitting
here and we're going to have a
conversation in the languages that we
share but what we're gonna do is like
I'm going to say something in a language
and she's going to reply in another
language and we're going to go back and
forth the first time I've ever done this
Luca okay as you know super super fair
comic to little dollars equator SI
quieres mmm defeats leper on fairy
crystal cambio cause evil or complicado
como Yaya Seton trainers todos possible
o CH my dad pero keep fast tenia most
impractical and Paquito Mary supposed to
explain your own yes I did answer you in
in in Spanish those you notice what if I
want you to valley alone could you
mmm-hmm okay done is mocked I'm be some
german deutsch broken or going into a
trance language paradise here exact you
know some people are funny but this is
just to demonstrate that this is not to
impress people I think this is to
express what is possible with a trained
mind I'm a language coach and you are
well I'm a newer language coach it's
something we don't use the brainy do no
you're not yes I think that the the main
the main idea is to really seriously now
jokes aside it's all about brain it's
you can see the muscles right and you
see the muscles rolling and it's you
okay that that guy is big you don't see
the brain growing you can feel it right
well neuroplasticity we can change the
brain and we know that and we know that
the bilingual brain I mean we have a
fourteen Engel brain here and it music
single brain here
so yeah fascinating just what the brain
can do yeah
and one of the last ones the most
important message is s actually is that
in the 21st century we have to make our
brain powerful because the technology is
changing everything and it's going
faster and faster we have to keep up
somehow yeah absolutely and you know the
the power of communication you the the
ability personally that cameo cuando
hablamos en otro idioma si es verdad
para me as siempre la misma pero con la
dos different sk insignias now and Luca
espanol Nanako me look it on the
analytic italiano
so difference is there on the sea pearl
italiano NK y ou quando sono italiana
fatso tutti jest italiana and Colossus
repellant with himself mezzo packages
will not focus on Concha panel along
accessibility know people need about
pure and externally de la preserves a
more commonly known and that's someone
that I used to say that the more
languages you speak the more souls you
have that's right so not actually what
Nelson Mandela used to say that he used
to see something beautiful actually and
that was if you've talked to a man in
the language he speaks you talk to his
heart while you talk to men in language
he understands you're talking to his
head that's right that's right and it is
about you know how can we bring
communication into speaking with
people's hearts yeah that's true and I
think that this is a message for
everyone who if you think that just
speaking English or just speaking your
own language is enough think again
because by speaking other languages you
can literally change not only your world
but the world around you and the world
of other people yeah but the beauty is
when you can change accents and I think
James now it's time to hear your British
accent please oh I'm not sure that I'm
up to the task
I will try away my British friends make
fun of me
they think I'm a fool when they try to
speak with a British accent I don't know
why but I'm trying my best
it's not the accent and used to speaking
but
Ayoo possible not italiano maybe in
scenario in Magento Romanova Shenko in
fact the Judicature philosophy NEMA
seriously duty so so la storia cerfancy
mink we packed if actual action to
remedy we got belaga Sobotka Bella -
don't know samosa duty progress - I
think a bank are you famous of enmity
see gamble mark facility Rosa Vega PD
resale aromas mega venus la cultura
Romana like a Saab Anka and of course
essentially its ECMO prop you see in our
Chancellor's that's you see molto Bello
thank you very much and kisses from
Roman absolutely big ol yellow banner
and we really want to say learn
languages love it
[Music]